[Musik]
sebastian zeigt euch was wirklich in
light butter steckt klar nur halb so
viel fett und darum halb so viel
kalorien aber was rührt die industrie
stattdessen rein vorsicht ihr habt noch
nie so viel geld für ein so billiges
produkt bezahlt aus zwei mach aus zwei
normale mutter
wie mache ich aus diesem produkt ein
volk produkteinheit produkt dann dem die
strecke
die strecke ist mit wasser stabilisieren
mit zitronen faser und färben mit müll
fettreduzierte butter ist der klassiker
im leid sortiment und zählt bis heute zu
den beliebtesten produkten für die
cremige beschaffenheit sorgen hier statt
fett zitronen fasern
[Musik]
mutter hat jetzt die phase bekommen
diesbezüglich ist jetzt vorbereitet für
die ladung wasser die faser hält die
arme auf und will das wasserfest leid
butter ist nichts anderes als mit wasser
gestrecktes fed dazu kommt noch
karottensaft für die goldgelbe farbe
fast so wie bei echter butter sieht aus
wie butter rief die mutter aber es fast
nur wasser wasser als fett ersatz das
grundlegende rezept bei vielen light
produkten
fast alle produkte werden mit wasser
gestreckt wasser hat keine kalorien was
er macht und was günstig für den einen
ist es leid für den anderen ist es
gestrecktes fett mit wasser
komplizierter wird es allerdings wenn
bei fleischprodukten und wurst auffällt
verzichtet werden soll wasser alleine
reicht da nicht schließlich soll das
ganze jahr schmecken aber wie kann man
echte kalorien klassiker wie frikadellen
als light-version herstellen
[Musik]
unser produkt benötigt maximal so viel
fett und den rest werden wir mit wasser
alginat und einem molkepulver ersetzen
um den konsumenten das gleiche wertige
gefühl zu geben als wenn da ein voll
fett produktes zu sich nehmen würde
ohne wasser geht auch bei der light
version von hackfleisch nichts und damit
die wässrige mischung später auch
aussieht wie echtes kommen noch
zusatzstoffe dazu milchpulver und das
schmiermittel alginat auch bekannt als
zusatzstoff 400
[Musik]
das hat natürlich eine ähnlichkeit die
kleist war weil es so schön schneeweißes
durch das milchpulver und die viskosität
dieses zähflüssige bekommt natürlich
durch das alginat damit aus dem kleister
ein perfektes team ii tat wird muss das
ganze eine stunde in den kühlschrank zum
aushärten
[Musik]
man muss sich das vorstellen wie eine
normale meeresalgen man kann selber mal
probieren sie auseinander zu ziehen es
ist ihre stabil vermengt mit magerem
fleisch ist die illusion perfekt in
manchen light produkten wird auch durch
proteine und stärke ersetzt
aber das wort wieder für neue kalorien
unseren leid frikadellen haben immerhin
rund 30 prozent weniger fett als normale
frikadellen dafür aber mehr gewürze und
aromen
das kompensiert den fehlenden geschmack
[Musik]
rico wie bei mutti goldbraun gebraten
also wenn man ganz nah ran geht erkennt
man noch nicht mal mehr unser eigenfett
weil es genauso gebräunt ist wie
normales fleisch wunderbar aber
zusatzstoffe wie e400 müssen eigentlich
gar nicht sein
[Musik]
in der bayerischen provinz finden wir
ein verblüffendes beispiel wie
fettreduzierte lebensmittel auch ganz
einfach und natürlich hergestellt werden
können mit ska josef pointner gehört zu
den pionieren auf dem leib markt ihm ist
es als erstem gelungen wo ist mit nur
drei prozent fett herzustellen
schmackhaft und vor allem völlig frei
von künstlichen zusatzstoffen
seitdem gibt es eine lite wurst in ganz
deutschland zu kaufen
[Musik]
meiner leitung nicht leisten salz
gewürze und eis
die idee zur bajuwarischen low fat wurst
ist aus der not heraus geboren durch
gewisse verkehrsberuhigung fußgängerzone
wurde das geschäft immer weniger bei die
laufkundschaft fehlt da ist muss
irgendwas erfinder und mein haus zu
retten auf gut deutsch sagt dann habe
ich mir immer an die seite gewagt zwei
jahre lang hat josef pointner an seinem
verfahren getüftelt die wichtigste zutat
für seine leid wurst ist magerfleisch
aufs bett wird weitgehend verzichtet
stattdessen kommt in die wurst
das geheimnis ist der
herstellungsprozess den ich anders
machen muss wie bei herkömmlicher muss
mit fact ich brauche im endeffekt andere
temperaturen andré drehzahl und da
andere laufzeit im endeffekt im grunde
genommen eine technische sei mit einer
speziellen gewürzmischung ersetzt
pointner den geschmacksträger fett aber
der trick hier ist nicht die
zutatenliste sondern das eis delight
wurst wird bei viel niedrigeren
temperaturen hergestellt als normale
wurst so finden sich die proteine im
fleisch mit dem eiswasser und werden so
zum perfekten ersatz
jetzt ist es im endeffekt kinderspiel
aber um auf das ganze konzept zu kommen
die mühe hat sich gelohnt bei den kunden
ist pointner slide wurst heute beliebter
als die normale ein erfolg der tüftelei
mit guten zutaten und ganz ohne
zusatzstoffe aus dem labor
greift ihr manchmal zum leitprodukt sagt
es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über ihr essen
wissen wollt dann abonniere die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips